COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY AUGUST SIX
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER.
OF PLEASE ADVISE OF AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDERS FEMALE TODAY FOR
STUDENTS ALSO CANNELLA LIVES.
MATTER SECTOR YOU ARE BACK
CRICHTON THROUGHOUT WITH THE SUN
FIVE SO WE'RE VERY GLAD TO HAVE
YOU CAN ACTUALLY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM THEIR CARILLO
CERVANTES SHARE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER HERE.
GRAYSON THEIR MAYES LAST AREA
PRESENT SALAS.
WALDRON HERE I HAVE A POINT VERY
GOOD SO WE DID TRY WITH MICHAEL.
TO HAVE GUESTS CAREEN WILDLY OUT
OF CONTROL SUCCESSFULLY SO.
WELCOME BACK --
WE HAVE EIGHT CAN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
SOBRE MERCER SALAS SECOND AWAY
MUCH FROM HIS AREA --
BETTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE CARILLO CERVANTES.
OR PROP HIS AYE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRACIA AYE GRAYSON
AYE MAYES NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS AYE SALAS AYE
WALDRON AYE WALDRON AYE.
MOTION PASSES AND A LIST.
RULES SUBCOMMITTEE IS.
AND WELCOME BACK